[Musique]
dans la revue blanche travail proposant
portée pour des gens comme fringues qui
a vécu près de quatre ans dans la rue se
nourrir est un combat quotidien
mais c'est ce disque n'a jamais foutu
couronne beaucoup ses trains à peu près
ça pour te nourrir le temps de marcher
elle une place aux vaches encore place
[Musique]
à 59 ans franck a eu la chance d'obtenir
une chambre à la mission au bouilh cet
organisme qui vient en aide aux
personnes en situation d'itinérance lui
permet de manger trois repas nutritifs
par jour malgré la pandémie
c'était comme seule émission on pouvait
l'espérer place le sentier dans la rue
il admettait pour ce pays berceau du
triste liste de formation catherine
vachon à 32 ans chef du service
alimentaire de la mission old brewery
elle veille à bien nourrir les plus
démunis à l'école jean toujours
intéressé aux questions de malnutrition
ont discuté de sécurité alimentaire donc
c'est pas prêt pour moi c'est le job
dans la cuisine de la rue clark l'équipe
de catherine prépare chaque jour 300
repas des repas destinés aux hommes et
aux femmes qui réside dans l'état villon
de la mission aux grues ici physiquement
on est dans le pavillon pour hommes mais
il ya aussi un pavillon pour femme qui
est dans le centre-sud
on fournit aussi la nourriture là bas
avant la crise on faisait environ 1000 à
7 par jour
conservez le maintenance est fermée
aujourd'hui publique pour des raisons de
santé publique de convier de l'autre
je reçois de l'eau sont fait brasser les
grades vérité le défi d'un organisme
comme celui ci est de composer des menus
à partir des dons reçus le compte le
temps pour gaspiller moins possible on
est quand même gâté en terme de donation
opéré aujourd'hui parce qu'elle dira
s'ils sont deux nations se séparer si
elle a travaillé on traite la viande
hachée ou pvc de la protéine végétale
textures et c'est la protéine du soya
ampoules qui est remis en petits flocons
pour faire la texture de viande hachée
dans le fond c'est goûteux une belle
jambe
j'ai les sésames voyage est jeune je
veux perdu toute cette belle nourriture
qu'ils étaient donnés par des gens
généreux donc faut passer ce message
s'affiche pas avec ce tout un réseau ça
manque de tout
boostés heures je voudrais pas que ce
soit face b que les messieurs y pensent
que parce que c'est végétarien que c'est
pas de ça arrivera pas là jeudi soir
[Musique]
c'est répondre patates douces sont
heureux tic on a servi avec de la viande
il n y en avait trop fait que je fais un
potage avec les cocos avec ça en plus la
patate deux raids plus goûteux vue
qualité retisse a fait mais aussi le
goûte la plupart des gens aiment se
tient petit crée donc ça parle bien te
dis patate toujours windows sous toutes
ses formes
[Musique]
oui on se fait des comètes ont vu très
bon très bon et ben tu vois ces
pâtisseries ou quelque chose comme ça ah
ouais tu les restes wales ou bien sûr
afin que tel mais michel avec agrium
justement c'est du bbcd géré mes séries
avec avec les riches peuvent ils peuvent
les laisser venir les bons ouvriers s'il
me dit catherine un musée végétal
d'haddaway séguin catherine avait trop
de choses un peu à part des autres est
bonne pour nous surprendre
j'essaie d'intégrer un peu de nouveauté
pour ouvrir leurs horizons fils de ne
pas ça marche pas comme une fin de set
up général tao et il en a qui ont essayé
qu'on dit est bon il y en a qui ont
essayé pas pu
mais quand c'est des légumes ne savent
pas ce qu'ils font les tirs de manger
des sous pour pouvoir défendre ou alors
le matin fatigue ne va pas bien être des
fashion décroché par exemple
étonnamment c'est ça va je me disais
c'est ce que je rends chez sont tout ça
en fait engraisser d'agresser dit je
puisse fêter vision de choses changent à
nous insulter concernant un peu chaud
si sa guérison qui sont à la vue le sait
souvent d'une façon
[Musique]
leur donner à manger santé c'est ordonné
variété dans l'assiette
le modèle de la city guy libre il a à
peu près un tiers féculents interpréter
nos légumes
ce n'est pas son simple de de s'assurer
que on eu de tout charpy d'une parce que
je pense pas que c'est ce que les gens
ils recherchent un missile de leur bon
repas qui fait c'est le maison
[Musique]
la clientèle qui a changé de visage avec
les coups durs de la pandémie semble
bien imprécis c'est un réconfort
on sent que les gens qu'il ya un élan de
solidarité et c'est qu'on nous aide
ce qu'il fait avec un beau soleil et oui
ce conte l'amour
[Rires]
[Musique]
ans